when he was a young kid I think he was
nine years old and his mom
had two I want to say
Russians or two Germans I think Germans
raped his mother
and she told him the story and he is
apparently lived out with the story you
know those kinds of enemies the Loyalty
isn't to you the loyalties into anything
the loyalties too that happened to my
mom and my mom sold me disbeliefs and my
mom believed in me I'm going to spend
the rest of my life make sure my mom's
dream becomes a reality because that is
an emotional story that I'm going to
tell myself over and over and over again
until it becomes a reality right like
what was his mom's dream uh uh it's not
about what his mom's dream was his mom's
you know the hatred she had the the pain
that the mom and the trauma she went
through by being raped by two German
soldiers I think is German or Russian
you can look it up on which one it is